das grundgesetz für die bundesrepublik
deutschland ist ein solides fundament
der deutschen demokratie es war ein
glücksfall der geschichte dass in
schwerster zeit ein neuanfang gewagt
werden konnte der in der besten
tradition der deutschen
verfassungsgeschichte und der deutschen
freiheitsbewegung steht dieses erbe
verpflichtet uns zu achtungs vollem
umgang bei allem berechtigten stolz
dürfen wir uns nicht darauf ausruhen
dass es in deutschland so lange zeit
gelungen ist die im grundgesetz
verbrieften rechte um prinzipien mit
leben zu erfüllen das grundgesetzes
nicht vollkommen es hat schwächen vor
allem aber drohen ihm gefahren
sie sind ernst denn sie gehen von jenen
aus die sich am lautesten als seine
verteidiger aufspielen
das verfassungs buchstabe und
verfassungswirklichkeit zuletzt immer
weiter auseinanderklaffen ist ein
alarmsignal
wir stehen auf brüche ganz klar dass sie
am lautesten brüllen
wir stehen auf brüchigem boden der
wohlstand auf dem der innere
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft unter dem
schirm des grundgesetzes beruht ist in
akuter erosionsgefahr zehntausende
produktive industrielle arbeitsplätze
gehen gerade erdrutschartig verloren bei
autobauern und zulieferindustrie der
chemie- und pharmaunternehmen bei
energieversorgern und kraftwerksbauer
mittelständlern und konzernen
die politik braucht sich an statistiken
die hohe beschäftigungszahlen bei
stagnierendem wirtschaftswachstum
vorgabe pizzaboten paketzusteller und
fahrradkuriere sind aber kein ersatz für
produktive arbeitsplätze die den
wohlstand erschaffen den der sozialstaat
verteilt
der politisch erzwungene umbau
deutschlands von hochleistungs
industriestandort zum niedriglohnland
vernichtet die ökonomische substanz die
den sozialstaat am laufen hält
und damit wird auch das in artikel 20
des grundgesetzes festgeschriebene
sozialstaatsgebot zum toten buchstaben
und zur leeren hülle
das ist eine direkte folge falsche
regierungspolitik in der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte wird die amtszeit
von bundeskanzlerin angela merkel stets
mit dem marke dreier eklatanter brüche
verbunden sein
erstens der euro rettungspolitik die
nationales und europäisches recht
missachtet und sich über die
souveränitätsrechte des volkes und
seiner vertreter mutwillig hinwegsetzt
der energie- und auto wenn de die
eigentumsrechte willkürlich missachtet
und er bis heute ungelöste migrations
krise die unter fortgesetztem bruch von
artikel 16a illegale einwanderung über
sichere drittstaaten faktisch und in
einer dimension hinnimmt welche die
integrität des souveräns des staats
volkes dauerhaft und dramatisch
verändern wird
damit haben sie sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin unserer rechts und
verfassungsordnung schweren schaden
zugefügt das volk der souverän wurde bei
alledem nicht ein einziges mal gefragt
und das ist eine der unleugbaren
schwächen unseres grundgesetzes das
misstrauen gegenüber dem bürger sehr
geehrte damen und herren nach der
wiedervereinigung
wurde in den 90er jahren die gelegenheit
vertan diese schwäche zu heilen
der auftrag den das grundgesetz selbst
den artikel 146 erteilt hatte nämlich
dass das gesamte deutsche volk in freier
selbstbestimmung sich eine neue
verfassung geben sollte wurde nicht
erfüllt
statt vom gesamten deutschen volk wurde
die wiedervereinigung von der
volkskammer der untergehenden ddr in
einem nüchternen beschluss vollzogen der
damit obsolet gewordene artikel 23 nach
denen der beitritt der mitteldeutschen
bundesländer zum grundgesetz erfolgte
war von vorbildlicher lakonik er wurde
nämlich ersetzt durch einen neuen
artikel 23 der die wieder die der die
weiterentwicklung der europäischen union
zum start ziel erklärt aber in seinen
zahlreichen absetzen weder dem volk noch
seinen vertreter das letzte wort gibt
sondern bundestag und bundesrat
lediglich ein recht zur stellungnahme
eingeräumt
faktisch also ein verlust an
souveränität und einer titel
der ein ums andere mal als freibrief für
weitreichende übertragung von
hoheitsrechten ausgenutzt wird
es besteht hier fraglos
verbesserungsbedarf
denn es ist ja klar jede verfassung auch
die beste bedarf der kontinuierlich
weiterentwicklung
dabei gilt je prägnante ein
verfassungstext desto größer ist dabei
seine autorität je mehr detailregelungen
dagegen aufgenommen werden desto größer
die gefahr der verengung und
verbesserung die achtung vor dem geist
des grundgesetzes gebietet bewährtes
schärfer herauszuarbeiten überholtes
anzupassen und anachronistisches zu
streichen
das heißt zum beispiel den 100
tausendfachen missbrauch und
individuellen grundrechts anspruch auf
asyl durch eine institutionelle garantie
mit einfach gesetzliche regelung zu
ersetzen
das bedeutet schluss mit ewig lähmenden
gerichtsverfahren ausreisepflichtige das
heißt deutsch als staatssprache
festzuschreiben was von 70 jahren noch
als unnötige selbstverständlichkeit
erschienen wäre
und es bedeutet volksabstimmung und
volksentscheide auch auf bundesebene
endlich in der verfassung zu verankern
damit das selbstbestimmungsrecht des
deutschen volkes an seinen ihm
zustehenden platz zurückkehrt
[Applaus]